so we got an email from someone and yeah
they just said hi there I'm wondering if
I can get involved with what you do how
can I help
I'm a multi-hyphenate from Des Moines
and I've done you know directing in
different things how can I help you I
think it's great that's fantastic
approach I mean that's exactly what I'm
talking about this idea I have a friend
who talks about networking in live
situations not having anything to do it
online and she teaches classes about
this and everything you know classes
seminars you name it and her whole thing
is if you're if you spend 80% of the
night asking that question you know you
target your people and ask that question
that she guarantees you that you will
get an 80% response meaning that you'll
get even if you get the answer in the
follow-up or right there there really
isn't anything that you could do for me
right now you're going to get asked but
what are you doing like what what are
you looking to do like what and you know
you might be compelled in that situation
to say well I'm you know I'm not looking
for somebody or you know right now you
know you can't help me right now but I
know somebody that well let me pass your
resume on to some of your resume send me
your information and maybe I can pass
your information on to somebody else
it's a great approach because it's a
selfless approach and how often do you
have somebody that you get into a
conversation with it takes a selfless
stance with you you know or selfless
approach with you it doesn't happen very
often so it's impactful when it does
when and again it comes back to that
whole idea of asking questions you know
what can I do for you I think it's great
and I you know I said earlier that you
know if you're meeting somebody
upper-echelon maybe that question
doesn't connect but it still could it
really it really could because you know
what I've known people who have walked
up to very very big directors you know
very very big producers and have asked
that question and it have end up you
know as an intern you know I mean and
maybe an older you know just saying hey
just let me on the set and I'll go get
coffee but I just want to see and
they'll say oh you know people be like
okay you know you never know but taking
that approach without question
is a winning approach it's it's the
right thing to do have you received an
email like that and if so how did you
handle it
I have and there have been situations
where you know that person has been able
to help me out in some way even if it's
you know helping out an event you know
saying hey you know if you want to come
down and you want to be a part of it and
you want to be in the middle of it come
down and and you know you could help out
you can assist in it and in a way or
sometimes it's it's even you know we put
on some live events it's you know come
down and help us the live event if you
like and you can you know you could sit
in and you know would be completely free
to you and and you can learn something
there we try to do a lot of things for a
lot of people like you know we've man
I've been asked by you know I've been
approached by students let's say who are
so passionate about what they're doing
and asking if there's any intern spots
open or whatever and maybe if I don't
have them I'll go back to them because
they're being so selfless and say what
are you studying what are you got going
on okay I have this webinar coming up
and it's normally you know or this class
coming up it's only $50 or snow normally
$199 it's you could go take it for free
you know I mean because I love the way
that you made that I'm always it always
kind of hits me right in the right spot
when somebody takes that approach and it
makes me want to help that person or at
least get to know that person if I know
what they're all about
you